thank you
you could have just handed it to me
hey GQ I'm Matthew Perry and these are
my essentials
this is my Batman hat I wear this you
know because I am Batman and uh it's
pretty cool
and I like to watch the movie Batman
while wearing this but just this
my love for Batman
um started really with the Chris Nolan
movies at Christian Bale being Batman I
thought that was really cool Mike Heaton
played him and he's probably my favorite
actor and this newest one the Batman is
really really good too so he's kind of a
loner he's rich
um
he solves crime I also solve crime
um so I can relate to Batman very much
also you know you're always able to
relate to Somebody That You Are
[Music]
this is probably my favorite thing that
I have so bad man watch when I got it I
was in Hong Kong No One understood what
I was saying so I had to find it all by
myself in a three level mall and I did
find it but that was one of the times
that I was like I'm I'm famous somebody
help me but I found it and it's here and
it's gorgeous and it tells time which I
think is good
okay these are keys to my car which is
National Martin which I was able to buy
because I was on Friends
I
drive this if I have to go somewhere I'm
not really a car guy but I do like my
car which is an Aston Martin convertible
and it looks like the Batmobile so I
drive it around to pretend that I am
Batman
[Music]
this is one of my favorite things I have
an iPad and a keyboard so they're sort
of attached but then you can separate
them I don't know how to separate them
there we go so there's that uh
I'm going to close it because you never
know what's going to pop up I wrote a
screenplay on this I wrote a book on
this
and uh
I should try to keep it to that you know
writing it's it's more elegant than the
other things you can do with it the book
is called friends lovers and the big
terrible thing
and it is about kind of my rise to fame
while battling this horrible disease
that I have so
um it's very serious it was pretty easy
to write it kind of fell off fell onto
the page but then when I had to read it
it was much much harder and much more
sad because my life has been a difficult
one and I was honest in the book about
that and when I read it I thought to
myself man what a hard life this guy's
gone through and then I realized it's me
that I'm talking about you know it gets
dark so bring you know a flashlight with
you
foreign
[Music]
in my office which is my favorite place
in my new house I have a
um that computer that I showed you and I
use that iPad to I used it to write down
the everything about the screenplay and
the book and it was just really easy to
write the screenplay and I was sitting
in a in a a real office chair but it it
was a Batman real office chair and as
the Batman insignias now it's gone way
too much I'm realizing today that I have
too much Batman stuff so I'm going to
get Wonder Woman stuff and walk around
town
[Music]
this is my favorite hair gel this
particular product was introduced to me
during a photo shoot where uh they
changed my hair all together it was a
cover shoot and they changed they cut my
hair differently and I stuck with this
because it was familiar but it was a
scary day because they gave me like this
crazy hairstyle and it was a cover sheet
so you can see here I use it a lot
because there's not much left but you
only need a little bit so this will last
me like a month but it's you know it's
sort of half waxed and half gel also I
am that way
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thing we have these are Batman sweats
and I will uh sleep in them occasionally
and uh they really say Batman on them so
yeah there's no personality
complex or anything because all I have
to do is look at my left eye and I know
who I am okay so at my home I have a
Batman room that is either called the
mat cave
or bat cave and it's just filled with
all my Batman stuff it's not really
special mementos or anything but I have
Batman statues and Batman like it's a
very full room because people finally
figured out what they should get me for
my birthday or for Christmas
okay this is a black uh t-shirt
I'm not really a big fashion guy but
like I like this shirt it's a very
simple black T-shirt works with
everything fits in with my car so
um I can drive around and
kind of camouflage myself with a black
T-shirt and a black line so it looks
like nobody's driving
um so James purse is probably my
favorite I even have a James Perez ping
pong table I'm pretty good at ping pong
all racket Sports I kind of excel at
because I played all the time as a kid
so I played for like 10 hours a day so I
like I like my ping pong table I'm
better at that than I am at pool yes at
one point I was a nationally ranked
tennis player boys under 14. I was 17th
in the country
in Canada you know the tennis is much
better in La so when I came to La I was
killed by everybody and had to decide
for a different career path
you said
[Music]
okay this is pretty dressy for me but
these are my black boots so if I I
usually wear running shoes and
Converse and stuff like that but if I
want to you know dress up I I bring
these
um this is the left one and this is the
right one well I thought these just
looked really cool and they go with a
lot of stuff that I own and again when I
want to be dressy I put these on
yeah these are sunglasses
[Music]
I like the uh
the fact that they shaved the Sun
and I kind of like that they're they
have a little John Lennon feeling to
them because they're
around so I think they're cool sometimes
if I don't want to be seen I'll wear
that Happy song and these glasses but
also sometimes that just screams that
you're famous so I try not to wear that
combo a lot but sometimes I do
foreign
thank you GQ for having me it's a
pleasure showing you my essentials and
you know by seeing them you should
probably know by now that I'm Batman
[Music]